[Music]
there's one question everyone's asking
in Nicaragua where's the country's
president this was the last time Daniel
Ortega was seen in a video conference
almost a month ago while he disappeared
as the corona virus pandemic gripped the
world his wife and vice president has
been telling everyone else to go out as
normal a key here in our Nicaragua all
of our authorities report normality in
all actions and activities by ourselves
they certainly do going into Easter
borders beaches and bars have been open
beauty pageants have been held and the
government itself has actually organized
mass events by this March entitled love
in the times of covered 19 even the
football league continues and is
apparently seeing a surge in
international popularity because almost
every other countries close there's down
you know so yeah we got a request from a
broadcast company in Sweden who
naturally showed interest in lively
games not that brain sir
officially Nicaragua has fewer than 10
cases but governmental transparency and
reporting figures has been questioned
power has been concerned about the
response to covert 19 as in in Nicaragua
we have concerns for the lack of social
distancing the convening of mass
gatherings we have concerns about the
testing contact tracing about the
reporting of cases I asked former health
minister and now government critic
daughter Maria Tay is why the government
is keeping everything open yeah
mood on me now this is all dominated by
the narrative of the Ortega Maria family
dictatorship which sells the story that
this is a perfect country a happy one
where people don't get sick and anyone
who says that someone could be sick or
dead with kovat 19 the official
propaganda is that this is terrorism a
strategy to bring the government down
that and the fact that Nicaragua's
economy has already been decimated by
two years of unrest but now that
everything is open for Easter the
question remains why isn't President
Ortega joining in the fun John Holman al
Jazeera